就是做就得教育情固罐主帮我这个皮肤底色也好了
而且我们感觉这个皮肤做完胎身比昨天要更烤的
我最近好像有点胸每天都吃了两三点钟才吃
这样老闆也做得很好
觉得脸上的状态是挺不错的
紧紧的,而且软软的嫩嫩的
但是呢,做喜不快就交人蛋白肯尽还是会流失得更快一些
所以今天分享我的回春恢复打法
肌膚灌住二点零半
这天我分享过水光灌住
大家的法会非常好
今天分享的是交缘肌膚灌住
如果你最近熬孕很多
或者是已经有脸上掛不住肉的感觉
又或者是你觉得脸非常的暗沉
那你一定要试试我今天的这个回春恢复有沉
效果真的很觉得你们肯定会很喜欢的
我们先复一个楼指导出叶
把毛控里的一些楼指
还有一些独赛物给他导出来
这样才可以让我们的皮肤通道打开
牺牲度会更好
然后我们可以再复会的导出的时候
将一个热盆
让他导出效果更好一点
10分钟之后
把服出来的毛控量起清掉就好了
好,我们把导出叶洗掉之后
然后再复一个酸洞火作二次熟通
这一部分可以让皮肤变得更光滑
也是为我们后面的
无复平打击处
我复一分钟然后现在了
去把脸上算洗掉
因为我复的是那种比较农叶的算
你们可以用你们手头上就有的那种
酸菜的洞火都可以
接着就是我们今晚的重头型
透霍的复一成欧兰雅的小米冠面双
这个就是姜元冠柱的这一步
那这一步并不是什么
黑老面双都可以的用
因为很多黑老面双的思路
就是单纯的去加做皮肤材身姜元
但这样效率就更很低
但小米冠它里面是有真姜元的
就是跟我们人起姜元一样的那种
可以被皮肤吃进去
就直接给你补金去了
用它就相当于是图抹时的姜元
就不愿不断的皮肤不重姜元
用量可以稍微多一点
这样出来的效果才会更好
我觉得它们家这个面双的香味好好
现在用一个基础的不选面膜的加一样
让皮肤更好的把小米冠柱的鼎样吃进去
随月一个普通的不选面膜就行
或者你搞个长水十分几
5分15分钟
今天给我的链吃得真好
现在感觉那皮肤明显的比刚才吸引一群一些
谈认了一些
现在可以在按摩一下
也可以做一个面部提牢操
我为你们说这一趟做完第二天
几床效果很均
其实我已经做了有一段时间
以前我也是一个一熬月
第二天我的链就会很浪黄
按成了感觉
多多是往下走的
链看前老我好几岁
就是做这个教研几分冠柱
把我这个皮肤底子扬好了
现在后续的乎乎就变得非常简单了
简单的同一个修过净环
再重一层这个小一冠冰霜
就可以去睡觉了
这个冠霜它真的很怕洗手
就是我是一个会晓皮
我就算腿大脱
它也不会说很逆而什么
我自己不要忘了
像我现在什么都没图的样子
就是教研淡淡淡淡淡淡
感觉脸很难的
阿姨咱们好
我心里是天上线
我觉得脸跟昨天刚做完的
这种它还真的没所区别
而且我们感觉这个皮膚状态是比昨天要更好的
都是很吸密很光滑
而且是在光泽的那一种
很Q弹不坚实
每一种做一次这个教研几部冠柱
皮膚状态真的会变得很好